and a new front is opening up in
Northern Israel with exchanges of fire
across the borders with Lebanon and
Syria well the Israeli military says it
launched artillery strikes in response
to Rocket attacks by Hezbollah Al jaz's
alih hasham is in nakura in southern
Lebanon for
us there is a significant development
with hamas's alasam brigades issuing a
statement claiming responsibility for
the missiles or the rockets that were
launch in South Lebanon today this is
very significant because if we put this
beside yesterday's uh Islamic jihad's
infiltration to the uh uh in the the
borders towards Israel and engaging in a
battle with the Israeli Army we're
seeing now a new Dynamic here on the
Lebanese front as I said before this is
an operation area and this operation
area is now engaging Palestinian
factions on Lebanese soil and this is
the first time time since 1982 that
Lebanese uh sorry Palestinian factions
are engaging directly in a fight with
the Israelis on the Lebanese borders
this is the the development that seems
to be uh kind of different than all
what's been happening the past days yes
hisbah has attacked in the past few days
Israeli posts in Shah Farms it
retaliated yesterday for Israel's uh air
strike on its uh positions today and
just a few hours ago hisbah issued a
statement claiming responsibility for an
attack on an Israeli military vehicle in
AV with guided missiles so it's getting
more and more complicated situation is
escalating day after day however it's
still it's still contained we can't say
that it's out of control but the more
the more there is blood the more things
are going to go out of control